une enquête ouverte pour pierre menez
contre pierre ménès pour agression
sexuelle lors de psg nantes l'ancien
journal de canal+ est mis en cause par
une hôtesse du parc des princes pour des
gestes déplacés possiblement commis lors
du match psg nantes le 20 novembre
pierre ménès conteste les faits
voilà et alors puisque vous pouvez nous
dire là dessus des 20 j'ai trois
attestations certains d'ores et déjà
pour voir ce quad c'est quoi une
attestation en fête officielle oui
pierre ménès était accompagné du lors du
match psg nantes et du parti voir le
match avec trois personnes d'accord ils
n'ont pas lâché ils ont été à ses côtés
du début jusqu'à la fin il est en loge
vous savez très bien parce que vous êtes
un adepte du parc des princes vous êtes
un vip
vous connaissez très bien ce que c'est
que les là je cherche syrie il ya 200
ans comment tu te retrouves leur
histoire
mais je vais vous dire que
vos carrés on peut pas la chose de façon
comme ça a promis cement donc moi j'ai
déjà ma position trois attaquants safa
bien sûr j'étais au courant il ya deux
trois heures d'accord pourquoi pourquoi
c'est quoi alors l'histoire non c'est
même pas de plaintes s'il ya même pas de
plainte qui a été déposée ces accords
ses lecteurs ses options de saisie ça
c'est le parquet qui voit là où saisi 1
voilà que comme toi raiarii habitants
elle exactement ça c'est un autre ça
c'est une autre affaire ça non mais
c'est le parquet qui n'ont pas du tout
avant ça c'est une autre affaire je
reviendrai parce que là c'est l'avocat
de la famille c'est pour ça que mon
geste la sacem voilà d'accord donc sur
pierre ménès
sur père menace je peux vous dire
honnêtement voilà si le parquet persiste
dans cette voie à vouloir salir mon
client je dépose une plainte pour
dénonciation calomnieuse contre x pour
savoir qui a intérêt ici à déstabiliser
mon client il s'est rien passé je vous
le dis j'ai les attestations trois
personnes qui n'ont pas lâcher du début
jusqu'à la fin ce qu'elle dit l'hôtesse
de la jeune fille que visiblement il ya
eu déjà steen approprié d'accord on est
loin de l'agression sexuelle dans
l'instant d'accord on sent on jette en
pâture comme ça c'est ce que je voulais
dire ce soir vous matière jette en
pâture ouais c'est l'exemple typique on
jette en pâture comme ça sans que la
justice puisse faire son travail
sereinement c'est ce que j'ai dit sur
rtl il ya quelques jours alors ce soit
pour la faire non pas de la victime
présumée victime tout court après
libre au juge d'instruction à charge et
à décharge de voir si ces éléments sont
caractérisés ou pas